let's go next to our caller from the 702
area code who's calling today from 702
yes it is and are we on speakerphone or
Bluetooth Christian you were but now
you're on handset yes I love it
awesome so I know you've got a lot of
callers I'll make it quick but it is
somewhat substantive been a fan for 10
years I'm curious on your take on some
policies I've recently read and kind of
changed my mind on ok I've always
considered myself kind of I hate labels
so I don't even like the word moderate
because it implies that the truth is in
the middle mm-hmm which is only I tried
to avoid extremes right and recently
I've come to the realization that a lot
of preconceived beliefs that I would
think I wouldn't like I'm a hyper
liberal in love politics even I I think
had been victim of a lot of propaganda
and information campaigns or
disinformation campaigns and I'm curious
if you've ever thought about
nationalizing natural resources much
like Norway does to their oil because I
was thinking about it oil in America for
example is ran by a handful of families
right and in countries like Norway the
country actually profits directly from
selling the oil itself with no middleman
and you know business
who in business likes middlemen and it's
kind of a strange concept to think about
me we're already talking about
healthcare right where I talked already
talking about education why aren't
natural resources being added to the
discussion because the oil is like a
trillion dollar plus industry well I
think more than just the size of the
industry I've thought about it because
so what's the argument right now for
making the internet a public utility the
argument is that the internet is so
fundamental to every aspect of almost
everyone's lives that the idea of making
it a saleable product for profit starts
to become problematic and I think that
would be the reason I think we should
get off of fossil fuels but to the
extent that every aspect of what we do
relies on them why are we allow
for profit corporations to take
advantage of that now the only problem
with that is they ground often the so
the argument that a pro-business Center
rightist would make is hold on a second
it was for-profit companies that took
the initial risk financially and often
it's more than just a financial risk to
establish the systems to harvest the oil
therefore it would be wrong for the
government to just come in and take them
over and I'm not completely I mean there
is some logic argument but that doesn't
matter yeah to some degree to some
degree like the subsidies that we employ
essentially it's like these
pharmaceutical companies yes our tax
like I've looked into it even the Bush
family right the CIA gave uh George
would seem like he didn't so it's like
to some degree yes there's gonna be way
what happened is zio that what it what
did it say I gave George Bush oh the CIA
gave George the Bush family their oil
start probably because he would no
invested in the CIA career-wise oh yeah
uh it's a crazy
I watched documentary on it but um the
point of all that is to say I know that
individuals are still going to be so
take you on musk even right people
criticize Tesla because it was birthed
through subsidy but the reality of
course is everybody wish they could get
a five billion dollar subsidy from the
government
not everybody's qualified to so that
doesn't take away from the credit of the
achievement of starting the company some
degree when we're talking about the
product the property of the country
itself because Tesla is not the part
that Tesla and the products it produces
are not the property of the country just
because they gave them a subsidy well
it's not a real axis in the same way
that oil is again right exactly right
and I'm with you also fossil uses long
term ideally but it's still a huge
portion of not just our economy of
international economy and it like you
said it just doesn't make sense to me
that these people profit the
pharmaceuticals are the most insane
example of that of course because
literally we're funding the the research
development start to tail end and then
at the end of it they go okay now we're
gonna rip you off that that's ludicrous
you know particularly when a lot of the
people doing the research went to you
know public school
and they rely on the justice system and
law enforcement to enforce contracts and
make sure no one steals their stuff but
yeah I mean listen from a practical
perspective Christian we're gonna get
off of fossil fuels sooner than we
nationalize oil so I think that we
should just put the focus on that at
this point well well and not to take
them which time I'm curious because it
is very radical right that's part of why
and this is I don't mean to take up too
much time but I'm actually curious about
your thoughts on it so I had a
discussion with friend once or a lot of
people are really feeling yeah
Andrew yang right now because he seems
like a young ideas-driven guy who's less
wrapped up in the politics of it so I
actually to be honest if I'm being Frank
I kind of leaned towards yang because he
seems a little more savvy okay hello
okay that's weird well listen yeah I
mean I don't know I don't know what to
say about Andrew yang I've talked about
him before but that was weird